maybe today as I kind of go through some
of what max point does some of the
problems that we deal with yeah you'll
come to realize like how I end up here
it's such an interesting area right like
and there's lots of just neat problems
going on and i hope to kind of give you
a flavor of that today okay so what is
uh what does max point do I often get
asked that question max point actually
does a lot of different things so you
know if you ask different employees of
max points you know you'll probably get
a slightly different nuance to answer
but you know the marketing tagline goes
you know we provide a leading business
intelligence and digital marketing
solution that enables national brands to
drive local in-store sales my take on it
is that you know there's a really key
part here is that you're using
advertising to drive people to show up
in actual stores right so that link that
max point provides between online
advertising and physical physical foot
traffic getting people to go out and
into actual stores it's a very important
distinction I guess for what max point
does at its core what makes max point
interesting is that yeah we rely and
operate on these real-time bidding
exchanges so I never undo this before
actually until you know you know finding
out about box points and then
interviewing with them and then
eventually taking a job with them that
there's this yeah this is fascinating
thing that goes on when you load up a
web page so for example if you're
surfing a web page you've probably
noticed that okay like in this example
along the top there's you know and add
for some sort of HD technology there's
an ad space on the right side there so
you've noticed this before as you as
you're surfing but what you may not know
is that as a web page is loading up in
that fraction of a second there's
actually an a real time auction that
goes on way
there's all yeah sort of i want to say
people but more often not it's rarely
algorithms like that are trying to bid
for the rights to display and add in one
of those placements um so this date this
this flow diagram tries to kind of
illustrate sort of like what's going on
there so yeah okay in the top corner you
see the web page is coming up auction
gets kicked off everybody that's
subscribing to the ad exchanges that run
these these auctions they get notified
that hey there's an auction are going on
and then it's up to folks that
participate in these auctions like Max
point to make that decision okay do we
want to bid on this opportunity to serve
ads in these places and if so how much
money do we want to pay to make that bid
and so that's like basic mechanism but
what I find really interesting is that
you know aside from Max point
participating in these auctions as a way
of delivering advertising to you know to
consumers it's also like a really great
opportunity for max point to collect
data so in each of these bid requests
yeah there may be some information about
who is surfing the web there'll be
information about okay which website it
is that these placements are available
on and sometimes even things like which
was the page that kind of referred the
user to this current page so you know as
this as this data becomes available and
archived slowly you kind of can piece
together a picture of the person who
served in the web like what their
behaviors and preferences might be as
you can imagine like the internet is
fast if you know there's all kinds of
auctions going on they have mentioned
they have to happen extremely quickly so
that the consumer will still gets their
web page on time but also yet when when
we store all this data and
but available it's its massive right so
like truly max point is dealing with
like big data in every sense of the word
and you know some of these interesting
numbers include that you know we work
with sixty billion bid opportunities per
day and making you know more than 12
trillion calculations per day so so of
course this means that all this
participation in these auctions it's not
done manually or there's no way it could
happen it's done algorithmically at this
point I just want to pause and maybe you
know one of the things I noticed about
when I first started working at max
point was there's a lot of jargon in
this industry and I think over time I've
absorbed it too but you know at risk of
like you know using terms that you may
not be familiar with because you don't
work in advertising necessarily i'm just
going to like rifle through some of them
up you probably hear me use the word
user when I say user I mean the person
that's surfing the web the consumer when
I talk about placements I mean like
those spots on the website like where
you can place an ad request is like the
request that the Ad Exchange makes like
for people to participate in the bids
bidding process and an ad impression is
what occurs when say max point wins the
auction then they have the right to kind
of put this ad insert this ad impression
into the placement that they want um
clicks I think that's pretty
self-explanatory if there's an ad there
if a user clicks on it that's what I'm
talking about there but the term
conversion that one is a bit more fluid
basically when I use the word conversion
I'm referring to the outcome that our
clients desire so so maybe someone's
running a ad campaign for diapers and
the conversion there might be that you
know the client wants someone to click
on the add go to their website and
purchase diapers for instance there's
some common metrics that are used to
kind of evaluate performance in these ad
campaigns one of the ones that's most
relevant to this talk is probably a cost
per action or CPA so it's really just
the cost of serving ads / like how many
actual conversions that you get and
finally you'll hear me use the word
pixel you've probably been familiar with
the word pixel like in terms of like
looking at displays and all that in this
case a pixel is something used to allow
you know someone to know where our users
been on a website that doesn't
necessarily have ad placements and
literally it is a 1 x 1 pixel image in
the form of a URL but what happens is
when one of these pages loads up with a
pixel on there that request gets long
somewhere so you know that this person
attempted to access that page okay so
yeah that's a bit of a but the
background of where max points coming
from and you know in terms of the online
advertising business that we participate
in I wanted to now kind of delve into
okay where does the machine learning
part come into play so I mentioned
algorithms being important and you know
if you taken any sort of machine
learning courses or statistics and
everything you can kind of think of many
of the problems that we're trying to
solve as supervised learning problems
right so you're basically defining an
objective in this case maybe you want to
minimize CPA or maximize clicks or maybe
just serve like as many ads to as many
people as possible like if it's an
awareness campaign and yeah you're
trying to like predict the likelihood if
you serve an ad that you know you will
achieve this this outcome that you
desire how do we come up with this
prediction right that the outcome will
will occur we have a bunch of you know I
mentioned we store all types of
information that we come across like in
these I during the course of these
auctions and you can kind of think about
these different features in three
different domains like you'll have a
picture coming together of like what the
users behaviors and preferences are you
also know the website that they're
surfing so you know maybe this website
is a new site or may
they're like vs like a sports site or an
entertainment site and also you have
characteristics associated with the
advertising campaign that you're trying
to run so maybe this campaign is you
know I mentioned selling diapers or
maybe selling tvs and you know the
confluence of all those three different
things might affect the likelihood that
if you serve an ad that you'll get a a
beneficial result in my work I focus
more on that user box you know a lot of
the work I do involve trying to make
predictions and about what the user will
do and try to further understand the
behaviour and characteristics even that
particular box on the previous slide
breaks up into multiple perspectives as
well so for example if we're trying to
predict whether users going to convert
when we serve them add we might you know
look at things like oh what's their
location which is very important for Max
pointer for trying to drive people to
actually go physically visit stores you
know I mentioned their interests their
demographics or whether they're male
female what age that sort of thing even
things like whether right in the if we
know their location might come into play
and affect the likelihood of a positive
outcome if we serve an ad what I've
wanted to focus a bit more on today is
this concept of retargeting that's I
think it's just got some interesting
properties like that problem that yeah
we're going to go through it's more
nuanced than I first expected anyway all
right so what is retargeting I got some
chuckles from this it's not as a okay I
don't think it's as nefarious as perhaps
your your laughs might lead to but so
okay so here's like you know a
dictionary or like marketing spiel
definition of what retargeting is its
form of online advertising as it
mentions but really if I were to kind of
break it down like really what you're
concerned with is if you know that a
user has been to your clients website
already
and then they'd left you know that they
were kind of like interested in in the
product or service or whatever that they
were surfing on the site and the idea is
that if they've left you can serve them
an ad if they pop up while surfing like
yahoo news later or surfing some other
unrelated web site and give them an odd
there to try to get him to come back let
me try to make this really concrete so
on that first page i showed gether is
like you know in the yahoo news page and
there were ad slots that were showing
like LG ads this might be like what for
example an LG website could look like
and i say it's hypothetical and actually
that applies to kind of most of this
presentation i mean you know i want to
give you a flavor of what max point does
but I don't necessarily want to give
away all the marbles so to speak so
anyway I might be deliberately vague in
some cases but ok say I'm interested in
buying a 4k TV so i might have you know
gone to LG's website their landing page
I might then surf around for different
products that LG carries like different
tvs and that sort of thing and on this
website there may be a page where you
can actually then look up where this
product is carried and that's probably
in this case like what the client LG is
interested in having consumers do right
to actually go to that page look up
where by the TV and then physically go
buy it so if i had found a particular TV
i was interested in and just right when
I'm about to go and locate where I can
purchase it but then my wife you know
asked me to go take out the garbage or
something and then I'll get distracted
essentially right LG would want to run
sort of this retargeting perspective
this model right to kind of yet get me
to kind of come back right and finish
finish what I was doing um and you know
like yeah that laughs that you had you
know that hinted to this beings on a
nefarious sort of thing I think it's
actually can be quite beneficial to
consumers
well because you know if you kind of
think about it like if I think back to
like male like I every time I go to my
mailbox I'm carrying like armloads of
ads like chew the garbage because
they're just not relevant to me at all
and also you know I don't have kids like
in online advertising if someone served
me a diaper ad I probably would not
respond to it and might find it annoying
a lot of these models what they do is
yeah try to detect your interest so we
actually you know serve ads to you that
you would potentially find useful and
interesting as well so there is a
possibly positive spin on this so this
example back here it generalizes to this
concept of you probably heard the term
or maybe not but a conversion funnel and
the idea being that at the top you have
like kind of the initial pages on the
website and as you get deeper and deeper
into the website you get closer to a
page that is useful for a conversion
action but it's much harder to get a
user there than to the top and at any
point in this chain the user might leave
and retargeting model would be useful to
get them to come back again okay so i
think i've laid a basic problem as a
supervised learning problem particularly
in the realm of classification I just
wanted to start delving into maybe like
what an implementation might actually
look like so I think yeah most people
are probably familiar with this idea of
like a machine learning pipeline so you
know you get data you might pre process
that data normalizing features like that
sort of thing dummy coding stuff if it's
categorical then you probably have some
cross validation to tune your hyper
parameters get the best configuration of
the model and then you kind of want to
test it test the predictions that this
model creates against a holdout sample
to really evaluate you know whether it's
doing its job well or not with be
targeting the data that goes into this
model might look like something like
this right you probably I
so over time you've probably amassed a
whole bunch of Records for a user about
like whether you know which pages that
they visited and at what time on a
client's website you probably could like
summarize that you know and aggregate
some of those features getting things
like okay number of times they've been
done to the website which particular
pages as indicated by a pixel and you
know the time of their first visit and
versus the time of their last visit and
from there those it might be some useful
features for helping you make an
accurate prediction in terms of what
will happen when you serve them an ad
like whether they'll come back or not
and in terms of using this data 11
library that could be quite useful is
scikit-learn there's like tons of
machine learning algorithms in there
it's really well documented and this is
an example like maybe in this case set
up a logistic regression have a bunch of
different parameters in there that you
would have tuned during the cross
validation stage and there you go once
you have tested that model you might
want to test it against a bunch of
different models different approaches as
well and you know it showed logistic
regression previously but things other
things I could apply here or decision
trees random forests were hot at the
time but you know the kegel communities
moved on to other things as well and you
know in this particular problem survival
models might actually also be something
you'd consider just because of the time
component and data censoring which I'll
kind of talk a bit more about in a bit
and once you have these models yeah you
basically have this bake-off right just
you know have them all make predictions
and then compare them against the actual
outcome and a useful way of doing that
is possibly using ROC curves which is
also a feature inside of scikit-learn
and you can kind of plot them out but
really the important feature is like how
much area do you have underneath that
curve and basically higher the curve
goes up you have more area underneath
suggesting better performance of the
model um so yeah that's kind of like a
basic classification pipeline that could
apply to this problem but with
retargeting yeah I was in I mentioned
that I was interested in talking about
this one because it's got some nuances
to it particularly if you're going to
roll up some of this data aggregate some
of this data like trying to get like you
know the first time you saw the user is
the last time and how many times you've
seen them there's some inherent
limitations to how effectively you can
do that so that might be limit that
limitation might be the size of the time
window that you're going to retrieve
data on these users for and because of
that you know what I'm trying to show
here is that between those dash lines
that's the time window but the first
time the user was on the site might not
be within that window of data that
you're actually grabbing and furthermore
what's the circle show the clear circles
those would be instances where the user
went to the conversion site or at a
conversion page rather and again similar
you might not see that happening right
because of the time window that you've
taken and you know and it was these type
of considerations that yet made me think
of like you know survival model right
the other thing is that yeah there's
severe class q inherent to this type of
data if you know maybe I can have a show
of hands how many people here have
clicked on an ad in the past week like
when you were surfing the web okay and
dori if you have fat fingers you know on
your phone or whatever but yeah it's
like a rare event right I saw you know
like a few people but up there and but
it's not actually that common and you
know to deal with that you really have
to think carefully about you know
strategies like are you going to
oversample the data to compensate
employees and sort of weighting scheme
as well I mentioned scikit-learn and you
know this is a PI data conference so
maybe I'll stop and just kind of say oh
yeah well Python certainly factors
heavily into max points pipeline both
for prototyping and you know and further
along in the production process the
tools and environments that come along
with those tools that are most
interesting are of course you know
python itself but the Jupiter notebooks
pandas for you know its data frames and
ancillary capabilities I mentioned
survival that one was a bit more
difficult in that it's not natively
supported in scikit-learn but then
Python also has other packages but also
if you really wanted to use our for
instance you could also call out our and
do some of your work there and of course
not Bob lib is it you know a very common
visualization tool that we also enjoy
further considerations for this model
that we had to grapple with were so max
point if we are you know creating models
I mentioned that we have to kind of
factor in that know these models might
perform differently for different types
of advertising campaigns and we often
therefore have to have a very wide
feature set to accommodate four
different different possible conditions
like 44 different between advertising
campaigns the problem with having a
super wide feature set though is that
you have high dimensionality and
therefore risk of over fit and you know
just a reminder like over fit is like
when the decision surface that you're
trying to fit or the or the surface of
best fit it's just kind of overly
reactive to like error and randomness in
the data and yeah there for having some
sort of regularization scheme was
extremely important like for creating a
model to deal with this problem but
ticularly interesting was that you know
l1 and l2 or common regularization
scheme
but l2 was actually a better choice in
this situation just because it actually
fits a lot faster than the l1 and also
if you have collinear features it's more
useful sometimes going to retain those
features and push them up both to be
small rather than discarding one of them
and also because of the skew the colossi
are mentioned and the rareness of the
the conversion events even with a
regularization scheme there could still
be over fitting after the facts and you
know here you kind of can start thinking
like a you know about properties of the
models that you employ themselves so for
example logistic regression just because
it is a linear model might just
naturally be less likely to overfit than
something like a decision tree which is
going to be just kind of more reactive
to changes in your data and then finally
you could also think about using some
sort of ensemble again on top of your
model and in this case I just wanted to
demonstrate you know a bagging
classifier actually might help to kind
of limit the over fit and really what
that does is that it takes your base
classifier it copies it in this case
like 10 times and then but each of those
those copies house like a slightly
different feature set that's randomly
selected from the original and it kind
of has the effect of smearing your
decision boundary a bit to make it less
likely to overfit and you know back to
this point about you know we run many
advertising campaigns simultaneously as
you kind of move away from this kind of
prototyping phase and start considering
production or testing your solution
across many different campaigns then the
problems of scale start to come into
play and you really need to start
thinking about like running some of
these models and parallel perhaps and I
think these days there's like plenty of
opportunities to paralyze
things so that you know if you're on a
Hadoop cluster you can kind of think of
doing stuff on the cluster you're not
produce spark is increasingly making
that sort of thing easier but if you're
still interested in paralyzing parts of
your pipeline on in an offline sense
Python actually has a really nice
multiprocessing library that kind of
helps handle that sort of thing so for
this chunk of code you you know
basically the important part is like
where it says num cores like that's
basically just kind of saying like how
many parallel pieces do you have
available to run your model and a pool
call it basically has creates like this
pool of workers amounts to the number of
cores variable there and there's a
thought map method that you can pass the
pool and give it a list of things that
you want that the pool to work through
and pool nicely kind of handles like
dividing up this work in the lists
between all your different workers
alright so um yeah I just today I just
wanted to give you a slice of what max
point does how it kind of translates the
machine learning and you know while
working in this space I guess I would
say that it's interesting in that you
know we have this standard concept of
what a machine learning pipeline looks
like but the business problem and the
data involved can really kind of
emphasize different parts of that
pipeline and and force you to think
about different solutions around that in
kind of working on this type of problem
i found that yeah some of your results
may actually defy your initial
expectations so being able to rapidly
prototype solutions and test them
against each other and evaluate them is
extremely important with an emphasis
maybe on the rapid part and you know
python is you know it's been a great
environment to kind of help facilitate
that happening and the space it seems to
be kind of just changing very rapidly as
we go along there's always like new tool
those and things coming up but it seems
like yeah Python has kind of been quite
firmly adopted by the day science
community and will continue to be a part
of it going forward so that's all I had
you have any questions and comments
please let me know I also wanted to let
you guys know that if you're interested
we're hiring so feel free to you know
let me know if you're interested and
also we have a booth outside where as
Zack will be taking questions and
comments as well thank you do you find
models that take into account feature
interactions very useful or do you treat
them mostly independent give them silly
games done in that it is it is useful um
hopefully it is it is useful and you
know where we can like we try to like
pull that in as well but it really kind
of multiple expand your your feature
space like very rapidly so you sometimes
have to be probably a bit more
investigative up front before you try to
incorporate like everything in that
regard know that surrounds your question
okay good hi you mentioned that then an
ad is about to come up you get a
notification and you won't use an
algorithm to figure out whether to bid
for this or how much too big for this
mm-hmm what wasn't here was what are the
features that we use to you to some NLP
on the text of the ad or and you mention
about user behavior and how do you get
to model use of behavior how do you
attract these features and sure aren't
any public data resources to play these
things things i work at medical imaging
machine learning but i'm not this kind
of data yeah no fair enough and like
part of it is like you know i mentioned
yeah like maybe I'm sort of like being
opaque about it because I want to give
it away all the marbles but also like
the other part is it's just max point
the machinery of you setup is it's
actually really
complicated never there's just tons of
stuff going on as for data though if you
wanted to play on your own like
definitely Cagle I've seen stuff come up
on there yeah you can probably grab some
of the data sets still yeah and kind of
mess around but you know back to your
first part of the question yet like is
there y'all this type of analysis going
on yes right like there's like yeah but
you know I probably can't get into the
scope of this hi um so I was cutest so
with all this retargeting and display
ads you creating a lot of you're trying
to create a lot of demand for products
right so you're trying to drive traffic
to stores so due to also do something to
manage the supply side so that the
demand is met so how do you balance
these things yeah and like I didn't have
a chance to get into this at all in this
presentation but certainly yeah I think
what you're alluding to is that you know
you yeah there's like a finite supply
and you may want to kind of spread it
out not sort of thing and our
considerations not you know and i think
you know in terms of what I work on I'm
kind of showed that you know we carved
it up into different spaces and I am
relatively free to kind of like work on
the user audience side of things but
yeah there's other other folks that you
know kind of work on on those other
pieces and it all kind of comes together
usually through some sort of an ensemble
in scheme in the end hey you mentioned
that you train models on occasionally
larger features basis to be sore
suitable for many types of scenarios
what's the benefit of that versus maybe
doing something like applying higher
level business rules and training
multiple models can you give me example
I got basically like if you already know
that you expect a certain campaign to
have different conditions or behave
differently than a different campaign
maybe you train a totally different
model and just apply sort of a filter a
row on top of that to actually route to
the correct model yeah I got you um yeah
I mean part of it is just that yeah the
the advertising campaigns we work with
they often are very different right like
it's just it is difficult I think
anticipate up fronts I like every sort
of possible permutation so that's kind
of been the yeah the main sort of driver
to kind of do it this way like it's more
of like a brute force approach which I
think Leigh now yeah versus what you're
alluding to right um but yeah that's
it's sort of the situation yes um is
there any value for your clients in not
just predicting the behavior of your
client of the customer the user but
describing the ideal behaviors of the
user as in a more general strategic
sense if so do you build any kind of
descriptive models around that
absolutely um the you know but like I
could go back to the beginning slide but
you know part of the description of what
max point is is that we're also like a
business intelligence company so while I
focused on the online advertising piece
certainly our clients are interested in
those types of questions those types of
models and and we definitely have folks
that kind of provide that type of
service yes hey so ace with advertising
there's a lot of like privacy issues to
come into it and seems like a general
principles like don't collect data are
features if you're not use them so i was
wondering what thought goes into like
choosing which features you're in a
track sure beforehand yeah the industry
is self-regulating in that regard but
yeah there are like yeah ground rules
for doing this sort of thing the the one
thing i didn't mention is that you know
participation in in these type of
auctions like in the sense of like you
know sharing your your info about where
you've been on the web and that sort of
thing yeah like it's you can opt out of
that right and yeah we definitely
respect that decision by the user so
yeah and then outside of that you know
even if we if you are opted in yeah
there's certainly limits on like
you know ethically and legally right
that we would respect yep I have a
question not sure whether you know the
answer so how does they read carpeting
work so basically your company provides
a library for your customer to load into
their website and then their website
will store a cookie you on the browser
lee their users right but uh when the
y'all can't your customers and user use
the website hearts they are retracting
kept records I say if I'm go to Amazon
browse a messy a TV and then I go to a
signal use our website and the heart
that targeting triggered by the cookie
that I'm interested in such product not
sure the website yeah i'll try to
explain i umm so yeah and and cookie is
just like you know a type of identifiers
we target actually can work on you like
using other methods of identification as
well but so basically yeah that scenario
you mentioned like you are on amazon at
that point yeah that is recorded right
like if we were running this retargeting
model and the idea is that later okay
we've stored that in a probably like a
table somewhere but you know later in an
online auction if your identification
comes up again right like we know that
hey yeah you're now surfing I don't CNN
we would identify you at that time and
match it with the fact that hey we have
a record of you on Amazon before and
then that would trigger us to kind of
apply this retargeting methodology right
to kind of consider whether we should
serve you and add that using this method
does that make sense like or remaining
asava young the retargeting
advertisement is coming batted you know
news website not really as a verbal
information on something so i was
wondering how that got embedded into an
people in company's website when you're
targeting happens hookers oh okay i
think you're talking about like native
it's like where it looks like it's part
of the content is that what you need
like
okay what we can maybe chat after Yavin
will get intronic yeah I'll try to get a
better understanding of yeah so I i just
have won a specie question for the model
so before the user getting to the final
page we call it the action of page right
action page and so I look at that
conversion funnel the user need to go
through page 1 page 2 page x minus 1 and
so in your model you have your label or
target 0 and 1 is 0 means getting to the
so we are estimating the likelihood to
for the users guide you to the next page
of the final page um the final page i
was describing their right but you know
I think you're alluding to the fact that
hey yeah this funnel is more than just
the beginning page in the final page
there's all these pages in between that
it may be useful to know whether you hit
those two but you could actually use
those as features you know categorical
features if you will for counts you sort
of describe a static kind of learning
use case hmm do you do also online
running on streaming data for example
you model predicts that you should go
for this bit but it didn't work out
that's does that result get set back
immediately to the machine learning
algorithm it's better this kind of
active learning yeah oh yeah I know what
your reference you and yeah maybe yes
possibly I wanted to know do you have
internal bidding wars between your
within max plan um there's machine um
I'm trying to think off hand but yeah we
have like machinery to kind of handle
that case but yeah I just know that I
can I can see the output in terms of
those scores or the predictions like
from my bunch of different models but
yeah there is machinery to kind of like
yeah handle those type of
conflicting interests if you will yeah
thank you very much thank you for the
wonderful and very insightful talk
around up with prosperous future